nina son 2001 International and public
affairs my husband got is an admission
Franklin in Oakland beer and I came to
Columbia with him and the Madhesis you
know that time the future a divisor the
professor Andrew Nathan and Andrew Nason
asked us what's her dream you know what
you're going to do in the future where
you stay america or where you return to
China and then we tell them ten years
later after we returned to China China
were recognized IV degree and cranberry
we want to study at Columbia so we
worked very very hard to make money by
herself not from my parents or his
parents yet big challenge I worked at
Ali's as cashier at the beginning of my
husband's you know PhD study for three
month and my baby my son was only two
and a half months his dream always come
to columbia law library that's like his
playground he become our you're not
connect our love with both of us a
marriage and australis his freshman can
be a college now the most important we
got confidence we get the understand who
we are who I am more than you know
before not like in China we all say me
there's a lot of the faculties you know
Dean's professors president came to
China and that they need a local alumni
support to host them arranged hotel
restaurant Patti plays reception place
or you know meets them you know
government officials are local media
because I have this kind of connection I
know how to manage this PR event have
the branding of Columbia promote
Columbia in Shanghai then later are
extended to Beijing in other fillies
Genie soon International and public
affairs
we are one of me in the future in I was
well done there so just to pack off of
them i feel myself